اه من بيت حنون ننا بقينا في مدرسه الرمال
ولعونا من مدرسه الرمال على الجنوب طيب
وين الجنوب بنا نروح على شفا قال لا ظلكم
عدل ماشيين على دير البلح ولا واحد يمشي
ويلتفت اللي بيمشي بيلتفت هيك ولا هيك ورا
بعض بطخه وظلينا ماشيين جبناها ماشي من غد
لحد الهان مخلطين بيت حنون ومن غزه ومن
جباليا والسجع و كنا ململم هيك مش كنا
الحرب علينا كنا والكل شارد من داره
كم مره نزحت يا حج بقينا في مدرسه حمد ط
حنون على حمد ولما خبط الاندونيسي والحال
وخبطو طلعنا طلعنا على المدرسه هذه والله
الموت ولا المدله والله قلت يا ريت طونا
في المدرسه ولا طلعنا والله طول الطاقه
اقول يا ريت ط اخونا ولا جينا يا ريت ط
خونا في مدارسنا ولا مشينا هالم انا يا
العجوز قادر امشي اكم كيلو انا قادر امشي
اكم كيلو انا يا العجوز امشي وراسي في
الارض واحد ماسكني من هنا و واححد من هنا
من البنات او الشباب زيكم ماشيين امشي يا
حج امشي يا حج
ولا انحر نحر حكم مين هذا حكم عرب ولا حكم
يهود